good morning Millennials good morning
counselor snitch are you ready for
snitch on the toast
hey snitch on the Cho's whoo snitch on
the toast eggs Mitch on the toast I
don't know if you're ready for it I'm
not I'm so tired I feel like I'm gonna
be a psycho during the show so this is a
full-fledged warning this show is gonna
be psychotic because it's a switch on
the tow situation so that always just
brings out like the worst and me or is
it the best I think it's your best but
some people could argue that it's yours
I think it's my best too but like for
those who aren't like so in the know and
like don't know about all the campers
like I'm sure it gets confusing I'm
gonna try and stay on track because we
have so much to talk about so much like
not only do we have to recap oceans 25
which I'm just so excited to explain the
hashtag I wonder if people understood
what we were doing I wonder if people
understood let's give him a minute let's
give that a minute but also we have so
many stories to recap like there's
obviously more than five stories to talk
about so we're gonna try and like slip
in everything else in the framework of
this show yeah and just shoot the [ __ ]
because it's been a few days and though
we did so much in the few days that we
were gone it feels like yesterday that
we were here it's true and what's even
though I can't lie I just feel like I
went to Vegas my body feels like I went
to big my mind feels like I want to make
it so what's crazy is we did the show on
Thursday on Thursday night I got a spray
tan for the weekend and it is only
Tuesday and it's already gone that's
just my said that she's a testament to
how much time I spend in the pool yeah
oh that pool you know like earlier this
like a few days ago I was looking so
great and now I just look as terrible as
you when you left me which is
disappointing but you know it happens so
let's get right into it
oceans 25 was because we were staying at
the Bellagio just like the oceans movies
and there were 25 of us and Claudia was
turning 25 so we were oceans 25 and
definitely a hashtag was you know a bit
out there cause it
yeah it was very smart I feel like it
was very smart but usually our hashtags
aren't we're just like steamy Vegas Viva
last scenes but I don't know I really
was adamant that we do this oceans 25
she was an advocate for oceans 25 and
then it took it took quality a little
bit to come around the end and it was
good
it was a hard note with them like
pictures were being posted meaning on
behalf checks so she just had to go with
it what's crazy though is that I've
never seen any of the oceans movies
except for oceans 8 which wasn't even at
the ball like that one doesn't even
count I never saw any of them me there
aren't even see oceans 8 so I went to
the watch them last night you did yeah
because we're [ __ ] oceans 25 and I
couldn't and I know the premise of the
movie and there was like a wall and the
heist and they kept talking about it is
if I had seen it but I hadn't but then I
went to rent it and I didn't have sex I
tuned passwords so I had to wait till he
got home and I forgot to ask him so I'll
go through it all again today oh well
you know what I did yesterday I started
euphoria I've heard great things um I'm
just I do not like it and I don't love
it I just am so confused as to what the
plot is like it's literally just
watching people do drugs and have sex
and it's like I don't understand like
why this was made a show like what's the
storyline here yeah I'm three episodes
in I believe there's been six thus far
so like I should you know have a grasp
of what's going on but it just like made
me feel uncomfortable but I'll continue
until I until I make a decision but I
just felt it was very interesting like
it immediately got picked up for a
second season I was like oh this has
gotta be riveting stuff right yeah and
now I'm just I was just sitting there I
was like I don't really the point maybe
you'll get to it maybe people are just
like so horned up for like I'm hungry
for that stuff I don't know drugs and
rock and roll that's what it is rather
than - the rock and roll yeah okay sex
drugs in high school Sam Smith zendaya
yeah she's great
actually that's kind of Jacob oh lordy I
love him ooh interest on you know what I
started watching yesterday I told you
loved Island US version yeah because I
happened to catch like a ad for it on
the day was premiering so I already
recorded it and you guys it is so boring
I don't know if that's because it's on
CBS and I'm just like used to are you
the one and like here we are you know
getting like are you the one light where
it's like I think they can have one beer
like no one's drunk no one's starting
drama some of the like the cast members
are really cute I like their
personalities but like it's just not
interesting apparently one of them is a
major toaster to the point where like
she's converted other toasters like so
now I have a skin in this game and like
I'm just waiting for a toasty reference
to be drop yeah but other than that
I'm in one episode there's been for any
watch I was in the middle of three when
I fell asleep got it I had a great sleep
I could not fall asleep until 3:00 a.m.
I said I got in bed at 11:30 so I was
like four hours of just lying there
did you watch anything no my TV was not
on damn that's tough I think it's
because I slept till 1:00 that day
probably and then all I did was
literally lay on my couch for maybe
thirteen hours on my phone and watching
TV that's so nice were you making sure
to use your Felix gray I was glasses so
that the blue light didn't affect you
yeah I was I've actually been super
cognizant of that lately well who don't
know you may not realize it but the
average American blasts their eyes with
bright screens for 11 hours each a-and
you were at 13 year above average counts
sorry when you consider how much our day
revolves around our devices it doesn't
seem so crazy but then you add work
netflix and chill' scrolling through
social media for us it's technically
work as well we can't eliminate
extensive screen time from our lives but
you can protect your eyes from it with a
pair of prosthetic scree blue light
filtering glasses available in both non
prescription and prescription so you
don't have to get off your phone them
it's not what we were saying you use
your phone to watch to toast everyone
who's watching live right now and
listening via podcast later on all we're
recommending is that you hit up Felix
gray and get a pair of protecting eye
glasses they filter out 90% of
high-energy blue light and eliminate 99%
of glare coming from your daily barrage
of screens that's amazing not only that
they're on a mission to make it
fashionable high-quality blue light
protection widely accessible by offering
a variety of frames for all shapes and
style preferences like I love my Felix
Craig glasses but Connie has a pair that
she wears all the time that are so
[ __ ] cute I was going to say they're
so [ __ ] good people always ask her
where she gets got them and they're a
few looks great and then we started
working with Felix gray and it's just
such a happy relationship
it truly is anyways don't go another day
looking at screens without the help of
some Felix Gray's go to Felix great
glasses comm slash toast for free
shipping and 30 days of risk-free
returns or exchanges that's Felix gray
glasses comms slash toast
Felix gray glasses comm slash toast
highly recommend especially like if your
toaster it means you're at Neil and Neil
probably
and you're on your phone and you can't
get off and you don't have to just hit
up Felix great glasses dot-com slash
toast v great glasses concise toast okay
let's recap Vegas okay deal
I do feel remiss doing this without
Claudia because it was her birthday and
for those of you who are who are
wondering Claudia is not here today
because she was taken down by Las Vegas
and not even so much Las Vegas but the
flight home the flight oh the flight
home from Las Vegas for us happened to
be one of the worst most torturous
flights of our lives and I can't really
there's nothing that the airline did
wrong yes they did you said that these
definitely did we were on time it was a
quick bike the flight was no longer
shorter than it should have been but the
it was torture and for me it started a
snitch and I went to the spot the
Bellagio before the flight and we were
feeling great we like we couldn't have
been more especially leaving leaving
Vegas like inside I wasn't okay but
leaving degas we couldn't have been in a
better position to get on a five-hour
flight we really just you know played
our cards super right
we were very ready to enjoy a nice
flight we were both in comfort I got
upgraded and you know what I was ready
we were feeling like noodles like we
just went to sob we were in the hot tub
we steamed like we got on the toxins out
we showered completely sweet felt so
clean I was ready for a flight and for
me I could fly I could fall asleep
anywhere let alone I was feeling it yeah
so the flight starts
I fell asleep her usual I fell asleep
right away time tried never to so I was
like oh this is me the greatest fight of
my life
right I think about 20 minutes in I was
really woken up by a woman in the row in
between submission I who was choking
coughing and and while that was like
really just like it was right it was as
the snacks were going around so she
obviously like choked on her Sam I know
but don't get me wrong cuz she was
sitting directly behind me she didn't
like choke and like couldn't breathe it
like went down the wrong pipe so it's
like get it together she was causing for
ten minutes straight and it woke us all
up and we never felt lack of sleep but
more than that the temperature of the
plane when we were taking off it was so
hot because Vegas was a hundred and ten
degrees all weekend my window up until
an hour in flight was burning hot and so
the plane was so hot and then everyone
was sweating and then I guess at some
point they turn the air
max but mostly in the front so it really
hit Claudia and she just over the course
of the five hour flight develop strep
throat which is why she's not here today
and it just it really is annoying that
we had the most amazing weekend yet here
we are just talking about our terrible
flight home no booze no need to stop we
will but it was truly the worst fight of
my life like I can't even explain to you
I was just it was just it was just
torture and then we got home and we said
and get home until like 2:00 a.m. oh my
god it was really rough but you're right
let's talk about the weekend was
incredible like the vibes were so skinny
the crew was so skinny we brought a bit
obviously 25 people like there were so
many of us from all different you know
parts of aspects of life you know from
like different friends of sisters
different places we've met people it was
just but that's what I said it's just
like when you seek out people who have
seen Eve eyes and then you bring them
all together the vibes are Seanie so I
wasn't worried but I went even better
than I would have ever expected right me
too and everyone just likes like cuz it
was like not random but like it was from
different walks of life like it was just
so everyone got there and was like ready
to party you know and like just have a
good time like we were like we're here
for 36 hours like let's just go to town
and we did that we did that so Friday
night we had dinner at Zuma at the Cosmo
which was just like so delicious and at
points it was like I was hungry and then
I was full I didn't know where I was and
then I was extremely full at the end but
I was also like wearing a corset in
Spanx because I dressed as Jim Carrey in
the mask that will also just like
elevate my whole weekend like my outfits
like by the way gloves in the club
cannot recommend highly enough I
couldn't use my phone my phone was in
the booth the entire night at the club
and it was liberating I need to get that
outfit in another color because you get
it like pink yeah I'm so obsessed with
it um if you didn't see my Instagram
check me out a Jackie O problems I have
to give a shout-out to my inspiration
which was Jade Thirlwall in the Little
Mix a bounce back video if you've seen
the music video then the outfit wasn't a
shock to you if you haven't seen the
music video you were probably like why
the [ __ ] did she get this is what in the
world
anyways that just heightens like my
night personally we saw a Diplo @xs oh
my god yeah and he was incredible that
night was just so fun like literally we
stayed well some people went
like 30 minutes prior but we stayed
literally until like they clubbed the
lights went on in the club and they were
putting the chairs on the tables like it
was time for us to go we literally
stayed until the wee hours of the night
and then and then we just like went back
to the hotel and gambled and I lost but
it's fine I like I've always loved it
blow but my friend Berkman Nicole
Berkman is Diplo's number one family
through and through um so no one was
more excited than her but on the way to
the club she was really giving me a
music education explaining that Diplo is
part of Major Lazer right Jack you and
like he has two other EDM personalities
so he was playing all these songs in the
club that a lot of DJ's remix out their
songs but I didn't even know that he was
a part of like where are you now with
Justin Bieber it's Jackie and that's him
oh yeah I just felt like I learned a lot
about Diplo and his music catalog and I
was thoroughly impressed he he was
really great and he's just like so cool
like he's so cool his Instagram is so
funny she's so funny
he's has it all going on he really does
and has a great residency at a great
club that's like indoor/outdoor
apparently the other half is pool and
like it was just a really cool place to
be I think it was in the right place at
the right time couldn't agree more
I just felt like I was like this is like
week a coolest place I could possibly be
I feel super cool and I'm just having a
cool time and I'm wearing gloves well
you were wearing gloves yeah and I'm a
density post Instagram sorry yes you did
that was really cool
that was cool yes it means you get like
all dressed up and you go somewhere and
it's just not the vibe that's a story of
my life yeah that is the story of my
life okay so then the next day we had
the most delicious beastie vibe of ever
I think it was I think you could go down
in the books I think you could go down
is one of the greatest males of my life
greatest news we were the feasting boys
for sure yeah except it didn't do what I
needed it to do which was I don't know
revive me but it still tasted unreal and
like the food was just it just it didn't
stop coming you know you know when the
Years start coming in the notes are
coming stop coming sabko yeah that's
what happened that's what happened we
ate it to Dallas at the Bellagio and
sanella is like one of the best
restaurants in New York it was somehow
even better in Vegas because it was so
beautiful and I felt like we were at
that Chateau that they say that on Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills
it was so [ __ ] beautiful in New York
like everything is just smaller and then
Vegas everything is bigger and yeah we
had our own private room I truly felt
like a real house I think that of
Provence I know it felt it felt super
elevated like it was it was one of the
best
yeah and they got us ready for the pool
party at the Palms I think the club is
chaotic a chaos with a K and that was
the highlight of my weekend yeah that
was so fun it was just like such good
vibes and like for a club it was like
super clean which I just feel like we
were all glad it was new because the
Palms is newly Brennan right so we were
just like having a great time we had our
own pool I'm like everyone was just like
we're like ripping shots but like we
actually we in the beginning we were and
then we were we realized that it was
like so late so then we just sort of
like we're sipping on the extreme yeah
we were sipping on mixed drinks and we
were just like in the pool I'm like
everyone's just like chatting and
chillin and it was Latin in Chile it was
a really great time I love the day party
that's just my favorite thing I love a
day party too that was just so the vibe
great chatting and chillin we were
chatting and chillin a hundred percent
so then after they had to kick us out
because the club was closed oh yeah this
is a common thing at the theme of the
weekend we stay until they kick us out
because the club is closing so like so
you can during the day apparently that's
a thing so right like they were holding
towels waiting for us to get out of they
wouldn't give us any more drinks we
remember we were gonna order like yeah
yeah they were like discouraging us from
ordering drinks and food and we're like
oh it must really be bad yeah I would
ever do that so we had to leave
we like [ __ ] around for a little bit
where we like didn't know what to do
with ourselves but then we all decided
to like go to our rooms get ready for
the evening
right um some people took naps that were
dastardly for me it would that was a
tough time for oh no for me me and
Lauren Elizabeth laid in bed and watch
YouTube videos like ever like Margo
LuAnn and Olivia were passed out and we
were actually kicking and screaming
laughing we were watching kotico I've
never heard of him but born Elizabeth
was like he's so funny you have to watch
and he has this like series called
that's cranes where he just makes fun of
people and honestly I was actually
having a heart attack he's so funny yeah
like you should watch it like he it's so
funny Jackie like he just like and he
puts these people's videos in the video
like making fun of them I don't even
know how he's allowed to do that but it
literally was hilarious that's what I
did during my oh yeah I gotta check it
out yeah then we had our final meal at
the Uni in Essex and it was nice a long
table I feel I couldn't see you at all
all weekend
I know because because Zach worm was
always sitting in between us it's true
and I just was never
counts what's good yeah didn't see you
all weekend um because it was like we
all have to split up for cabs whoever
you got in a cab with was who you were
sitting at the table I'm like if you
didn't like it was just tough to see
some people yeah so clearly there were
some people I saw so much of the time
like I saw so much Berkman I saw so much
Lauren Elizabeth Rebecca and Deana and
Zach I feel like I saw all those same
people too mmm so so we go wrong I don't
know I don't know maybe it's just cause
like we hang out at home all the time
like I wanted to see my la friends right
yeah
two of them to be really friends you
know um no yeah yeah that's true but
like I think it's like we I feel like we
definitely saw each other like as much
as I saw anyone else but because I'm so
used to a hundred percent sure I mean at
seventy five percent so I feel like I
did to you I definitely did not see
Claudia I saw Claudia
yeah no cuz i know cuz I feel like I saw
Ben because I was always sitting next to
Ben he was saying X to Claudia and like
I couldn't get I was those on that other
side I couldn't get past yeah you know
okay I got it
so it was such a wonderful weekend a
wonderful crew like I just
it was my expectations were obviously
like teeny as hell but it was just a
perfect weekend unless I mean oh you
didn't go but the night did continue on
after I say sorry so after that we went
to marquee where we dropped the dead
weight and everyone went home but we're
people but they were four they were four
main characters where it was knees ACK
Claudia Margot Lewin yeah four main
characters oh and I saw a lot of Margo
lemon so I guess that's like the whole
trip
so then we went to marquee where lil
Dicky was and honestly it was so pretty
we have like we just had a blast like I
took my shoes off and I was just [ __ ]
dancing and it was it was really like a
great time but then little Dicky went on
and like I I'm fine with little Dicky I
know he had one song earth you know yeah
and I woke up in Chris Brown's body yes
which is like is that still okay
apparently is he saying it and he just
like mmm didn't do it for me like he
just made me feel super uncomfortable he
like gave a girl a lap dance onstage and
was like being super weird and his music
really isn't good at all and didn't even
sing
I feel like he's like the 2019
weird al' yeah or was what's the people
who said um who saying I just had to
Island yeah like he gives me like a
joking rapper vibe right right right
that's what it was I guess he was like
fully singing rap songs I had never
heard okay but then he sing Freaky
Friday and I was like fine with that but
I don't know he like ever we were all
like there and we were just like this is
weird and so we just like left after
that I don't know but you had a great
time yeah I really had a blast I danced
bass so what was your highlight Oh me I
think my highlight was Friday night
Friday night was so [ __ ] [ __ ] fun
yeah and I didn't even have to get that
turn like I stopped because if I had
been hungover just one of the days like
it would have been I wouldn't be able to
I would still be in Vegas right now cuz
I wouldn't be able to get ya know um
Friday night was so fun like literally I
had so much fun that at 6:00 a.m. I
didn't want to go to sleep because I was
having so much fun so but yeah I went to
sleep and then I woke up at 12 and then
we had sit out like I was just kept
getting so excited look as we like never
really had to wake up early that was
like I was always able to sleep in yeah
even for the day that we left cuz our
flight was late which is why we got home
at never o'clock at never o'clock okay I
feel as though it might it's probably
time Robin I always like dip back in and
out you know when we start remembering
stories and stuff but I would be remiss
if I didn't let you know that it's time
for the Fast Five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast also I
would feel extra remiss if I didn't let
you know that today's episode of the
morning toast is brought to you by MTV's
the real world
Atlanta streaming now only on Facebook
watch the original reality show is back
and streaming now only on Facebook watch
MTV's the real world Atlanta is next
true story of seven strangers picked to
live in a house and have their hookups
screw-ups apologies fights tears voices
and lives streamed exclusively on
Facebook watch it's the return of the
first unscripted show in TV history that
tackled gender race AIDS taboos life
death addiction connection acceptance
and reality and it's being reinvented
MTV's the real world Atlanta is an
all-new reality experience with content
dropping daily and new episodes every
Thursday that's so exciting I know what
happens when the next generation stops
being complate and starts getting real
again it in facebook click on the
facebook watch icon and search
real-world on watch MTV's the real world
Atlanta streaming now only on Facebook
watch that is so exciting and so
invented and like just so
technologically savvy I mean personally
I'm all about the Streamy vibes clearly
clearly so I'm a big supporter of this
and I can't wait to watch for some
actual drama for some actual drama yeah
yeah streaming bags are the way to go
like people don't even watch cable
anymore no they really don't I only have
one cable box of my house now
damn remember the story Berkman told us
about our cable box
ohyeah it's like I had to be there yeah
and the way that she tells stories it's
like if I told that people like okay so
then what yeah that's it she's really
good delivery totally okay now 21
minutes later it is time for the stories
that you need to know in time so many so
I'm gonna have to get through them first
up Lady Gaga's makeup line available for
pre-order for Amazon Prime day 2019 okay
so in the time since we last spoke
Lady Gaga actually probably before that
we just didn't mention it Lady Gaga
announced that she is launching a makeup
line called the laboratories you have it
mouth do you follow her on Instagram no
that's probably why little monsters
rejoice Lady Gaga's brand new makeup
line is available for pre-order starting
Monday house laboratories is shoppable
exclusively on Amazon so it's fitting
that 2019 prime day shoppers would get
first dibs on the goods everything will
ship in September when the beauty brand
officially launches okay so this is kind
of neat giving me vibe aside it was
supposed to be launching on prime day
and it got pushback but they're gonna
let people preorder it to get in on that
like Amazon Prime promo did you order
anything no I didn't order one thing I
just couldn't even think about it
because I've been following along with
the videos and the vibe is very you know
gothic I'm sorry another prime day oh no
me neither
no no I didn't because I just I've never
even mind I wasn't in the mood to like
go searching for stuff and the last
thing I need to do is shop know for sure
oh yeah I haven't even seen anything um
Lady Gaga makeup wise but like I just
feel like I don't need her makeup yeah I
love her I love everything she does and
I don't want to you know sit here and
and say otherwise but this isn't just
this isn't something that I feel as
though I need I feel like she should do
like a clothing line yeah that
be cool or you know another album oh
well yeah but she's clearly trying to
diversify her creativity and like
everyone just thinks it's time for a
makeup line like you know get that easy
money and I which I understand and but I
feel like that markets getting too
saturated but a people aren't gonna
purchase fans as much as I'm a major fan
of hers like I go to every single show
and I love her and I buy everything on
them I don't consider myself a little
monster for some reason okay you know
but I feel like the little monsters will
love this that's fair yeah probably so
I'm happy for them for me personally
like I feel great with where I'm at
between like Kylie cosmetics and centi
like that's enough right k'kaw and I
don't use your makeup but I just got my
delivery a case mine hasn't come yet
oh my god but I logged on it the minute
I had an alarm I logged on the minute it
went live and I put three things in my
card I'm at the end I could only get one
because the website was so slow for me
that as I was checking out things were
selling out so I didn't get the body
foundation I just got the shimmer and I
tried it on and it seemed good but like
I didn't get what I wanted oh that's so
interesting because you logged on it
noon I went down a 12:11 because I was
in the middle of the wax and I got my
foundation and everything maybe what you
try to get fair mmm the one light I
think I got the light /medium oh my god
I need to steal something like in a
little jar okay your should be coming
soon though I know I'm jazzed I really
what could have used it this weekend I
kept thinking that well I have my spray
tan soap but in general like I will be
using it I can't I just keep waking up
with new bruises on my legs that's Vegas
counts it's so what no but it's been
happening all summer I mean maybe it's
been a crazy summer maybe um so that's a
cool promotion that she's doing it
through Amazon I'm sure it'll be
fruitful and multiply for her ah yeah I
don't know what else to say yeah no me
neither happy for her won't be buying it
yeah good like if you're buying it let
me know what you think like maybe
there's something in there that will be
life-changing look forward to it open to
the possibility yeah okay next story um
it's just a story about a person that we
love so dearly
Oh been having a really exciting time in
her life and is using this exciting time
to reflect back on the not so positive
times and I'm just so here for it so
Olivia cocoa parties in Miami in Miami
after
opening up about depression and I want
to read what she posted on her Instagram
verbatim because it was so beautiful it
deserves you know not someone's height
likes emphasis right is it half fast or
half-ass half-assed I think like half an
ass I don't know okay
so she posted two picture two selfies of
her on her Instagram the one where she's
like looking so beautiful and the other
where she's also looking beautiful but a
little bit more sullen in the face
what's that word hallo
John John yeah John was the word she
said looking at the difference between
these two photos today and thought it
was important to share something with
all of you second photo a few months ago
I was depressed I had no appetite was
drinking way too much smoking couldn't
sleep and couldn't eat but I was still
taking photos on social media and
pretending everything was great I was
going through a difficult situation I
left me mentally emotionally and
spiritually bankrupt and had take it had
taken its toll on me physically the de
feeling of despair is a relatable one so
I feel a responsibility to anyone else
going through something difficult to say
that it's okay to not be okay first
photo is from earlier the is from the
other day and I am looking healthier I
have my appetite back and I'm treating
my body correctly we're all too familiar
with the highlight reel of Instagram so
I wanted to get real and tell you it's
not always as amazing as it seems I'm
sharing this because one I want to
emphasize what we already know Instagram
is everyone's best version of themselves
in their lives it can trick us into
thinking everything is purpose in others
worlds which is not true we are all more
like than we think
navigating life with similar ups and
downs good times and bad we never really
know what someone is going through so
I'm there to judge and compare to I hope
that says helps others who might be
going through a hard time and feeling
like they need to have it all together
social media can create a crazy amount
of pressure to live up to an idealistic
standard of perfection okay there's a
bit more but that's the gist of it and I
just feel so I love when somebody's do
this in general and when it comes from a
really real place and when they think
about it like Olivia Copa was the
definition of Instagram perfection like
to me maybe you know what I mean she's a
definition of like I look at this person
what are they worried about okay it is
most impactful coming from her for some
reason because she is like not that I
think she sets these expectations for
people but like every she is one of
those people whose Instagram seems so
[ __ ] perfect
agreed so it was so real of her and like
just cooled it to point this out and
like show pictures and tell us when it
was happening because I feel like so
many times people go through it they say
you know once upon a time I went through
this and it's like oh I wonder when that
was what did that look like it seems the
same but I actually do remember two
months ago and I think I said to you
like her Instagram just seemed like she
wasn't totally there like she was
posting a lot of throwbacks or like you
know she's always so busy doing so yeah
I felt like she wasn't and I'm glad she
took that time out for herself right but
like if you think about it like two
months ago she was like - probably
shooting like the maxim maglite that she
where she topped the Maxim Hot 100 List
and that was also like when Dani wrote
that well that I know and that's
probably why yeah exactly so it's cool
to know that she's not perfect and
things do affect her and but she also
goes through just like I'm speaking of
celebrities with perfect lives that you
think going through third did you see
Kylie's Instagram last night I like one
of what I am I saw this that I thought
it was great - yeah I want to talk about
the Kylie skin trip in a second and I
just want to like shout out Olivia Cobo
for going there with us and keeping it
real and she seems so happy and bubbly
in Miami and Christian McCaffrey II and
I honestly Danny Amendola who I know Dan
even know who so the news about her and
Christian is now um like public
knowledge thinks the morning toast and
the toasters on the ground uh and I
couldn't be happier for them me too like
honestly he's so hot she's so hot
they're great like love it I hope it
works out I yeah and I'm happy for you
because I know you were really worried
about
yeah but then Danny Amendola literally
imploded yeah he lost his goddamn mind
he lost his Patriots whatever he keeps
getting traded clearly things aren't
working out for him bye and that's what
happens when you screw with Olivia
that's what happens when you screw with
Olivia culpo I wouldn't recommend it
friends okay let's talk about Kylie for
a second okay because our Kylie skin is
not a story though I really wanted to be
we just have like so much to get through
um and I like had a really important
request for one of the stories she
didn't so kylie is on the trip of a
lifetime sponsored by Kylie skin with
all of her best friends
excluding Jordan woods including Sophia
Richie and it just looks like it is a
dream yeah interesting Caicos Kylie
respects the hell out of Turkey I people
those words were coming out of my mouth
she respects the hell out of Turks and
Caicos and I respect the hell out of her
respecting the hell out of Turks and
Caicos no totally
so they I'm sure everyone has seen they
chartered a jet kylie skin branded
everything is kylie skin she's coming
out with Kylie skin body so like
moisturizers sunscreen SPF oil yeah like
that so I mean we were all gonna buy it
anyway and now like I guess if I buy it
I'll wind up on a private jet in Turks
and Caicos is that what she totally at
first I thought she got a plane and I
was like okay like this this make sense
fiscally and then she didn't and I guess
like she also it so very cuz she can
write it all off yeah I think that was
the main reason yeah I'm glad she didn't
get a plane cuz I don't think she needs
one cuz she doesn't really go that's
sure but like she could but she couldn't
if she wanted to so she's with all her
friends just like stuntin on these hoes
and by these hoes like not that she's a
ho Jordan Woods oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
das are twinning left and right which is
their new favorite thing I know which is
my new favorite thing and it's just a
premium experience and then I'm so happy
that Sophia literally med say that I
don't like I guess they have to take
some time because it was maybe a because
they were really friends before the
whole Scott Courtney of it all and then
that happens I guess like how those like
okay like you guys figure she then I'll
come back in with he told some friends
with blac Chyna and then when things
when Kylie started dating Tyga Kim and
China were no longer friends and then
when she started getting robbed like
they were able to be friends again it
just wasn't it just yeah it wasn't the
same so I guess if Sophie and Scott ever
break up then there might be a little
bit of a shift or it could be a French
Montana situation right true but they
didn't know both the French Montana and
Khloe was like a few months like they've
been dating for a couple years now so I
think it might be a little weird but
anyway I love Sophia Sophia Richie so
much and I really like I want her and
Kylie to be like the best of friends
I wonder how Kourtney feels about it she
must be like decently okay with it yeah
her to allow it but I wonder what she
feels inside I know and why I think
Kendall on this trip I think I was
really busy she's in like year up with
her friends like they really have their
own their own groups of friends like all
hang out they do sometimes putting those
hands and Kylie sometimes yeah but it's
like I feel like they just like their
their sides and then and then they'll
come together they want I can only make
it that we all have our own friends and
then we all come together
my friends I'm tied up you know what I
mean yeah that's true okay I'm a family
dynamics are weird yeah sure
anyways Stormies there too like we're
seeing a precious gem and she's just
living the dream however then she goes
ahead and lets us know last night she
posted to her Instagram I'm proud of
myself my heart and my strength
growing up the light with a million eyes
on you just isn't normal I've lost
friends along the way and I've lost
myself too sometimes my first tattoo was
sanity to remind myself every day to
keep it I've struggled with anxiety my
whole young adult life and after my baby
I dealt with all the internal ups and
downs I felt like I had to find myself
completely again I keep a whole lot to
myself but just wanted to share and let
you know I'm human my life is not
perfect and what you see here on social
media is just the surface which is like
she's at the ultimate high of her life
and she's letting us know this and I
just appreciate it
yeah and I love her saying I am a human
because like people just don't think she
is be gentle with yourself move on and
let go we are all capable of great
things worthy of love and allowed to
express ourselves do more of what makes
you happy and beyond College etic now is
your season we all have a magnificent
destiny and it what's so great is last
night as I said I couldn't sleep and she
posted this at like literally 1:30 a.m.
and I was you know obviously as pretty
girl my anxiety was keeping me away and
I rolled over you're never just like
laying awake thinking about nothing no
it's impossible not to think about the
things that keep you up at night right
and I got your app right so I rolled
over and I saw that and I was like huh
that's nice didn't help me go back to
bed but I thought it was a great message
to see at that time yeah and it's just
cool that she's posting it in the midst
of like the most premium content she
looks amazing like her business is
booming like becoming better yeah but
even I'm just so here for the realness
of these people that I love I'm so here
for the realness of these people that I
love thank you everyone thank you
everyone you know cuz like times are
tough out here my friends and like
social media really doesn't help like I
know such an animal about social media
sometimes but then like honestly wearing
the gloves really helps me unplug no
yeah lately I've been hating my phone
like I just I can't even go on it I've
really been liking TV do you mean like
watching television I there I stopped
for a while and now I just like throw my
phone across the room and I just watch
TV and everyone else and go [ __ ]
themselves yeah I totally hear that well
speaking of the Internet
time's 2019 most influential ppl people
on the internet internet list has come
out they are letting everyone at the top
25 most influential people online and
it's it's pretty legit
are you there no honestly like okay
since it was only a list of 25 obviously
and it's like Megan Marco Ariana Grande
and Trump like party B I understand why
we didn't make it but if it was like a
list of I don't know 500 I thought it
was the oh I thought if this was more so
like digital like influencer types not
like they're a celebrity's online there
is that list too um there are other
internet lists that come out this
happens many times and it's only 25 and
there are some you know like what's that
girl you like I'm a Chamberlain is on
here she I just need to talk about her
career cuz all of a sudden she went from
like just like being like a girl like on
Instagram I mean on YouTube to like
she's the lab she like had a New York
Times like spread like all these things
like working with Louie Vuitton like
literally she just went from zero to 100
and I loved her so much
I think she probably has like really
good management yeah you know like why
her why now that shirt well I see people
were saying cuz what's-his-face took
over on in YouTube fashion or Derek
Terra class yeah so like maybe he was
like he's maybe one of her or maybe he's
super into he is unbelievably into the
Dolan twins - do you follow him on
Instagram no but I stalk okay cuz he's
really into and his captions are and his
content are premium and like he's
friends with all these cool people and
and he shows us the coolness yeah he
pulls back the curtain so ya know there
are some influence like influencers I
mean BTS is on here there are some
political people
Liza Koshi I was gonna say like O'Shea
James Charles never has never been more
influential honestly I started following
him because of all the drama and like
it's a premium experience it really is
also the person behind the world-record
egg is on here and now we know who the
person is it was it Chris Godfrey he
works at a London advertising agency he
must have like a lot of influential
friends though because has he done
anything since what was it when did what
did it break - something was like Hulu
or something oh yeah something with and
like a charity yeah it was charitable
nice there are some journalists on here
Joe Josie was here um it's a pretty
useless um
I agree with it I mean if i sat here
long enough I could probably think of a
few people that they didn't include that
I think are influential on the Internet
honestly Olivia culpo
true but she's tapping other lists and
Kylie Jenner it's not on here that's
weird
and she's introduction no it should have
been the Kardashians because they have
groups of people like Hong Kong
protesters so like they could have said
it the Kardashians
that's weird maybe they just didn't want
to give it to him maybe Jameela Jamil
Claudia will be happy about that he
won't be happy about that
her it's our house yeah we did and
Claudia let her know she's a big fan for
activist yeah so cool I think I mean
they got it mostly right there's enough
like influential people to go around it
was probably hard to whittle it down to
25 that's true there's so many
influential people and now that I think
about it I don't know that Megan and
Harry are the most influential people on
online they're hardly online they don't
even post to their own Instagram
influential people like just in in the
grand scheme of life hon dopey online I
don't think so
yeah I could have gone for some more
like actually digitally routed people me
- that's what I'm saying when you said
this I thought it was like digital
influencers but no it's not but it isn't
it matter like looking - Oh Queen Debra
Granik I love it I don't know why I owe
it always comes back to them but I think
that they're so influential and like
their I love everything about them and
they like have their own brand and
everything I'm not just like influencers
they should be honest there should have
been at least one fashion influencer to
represent them all
I would nominate Olivia Copa but even
I'm Kiara
you know ara that's true Kiara super
influential Lauren Elizabeth influences
me all the time Lord Elizabeth is the
biggest influence on my life you know I
love her so much I literally can't even
say it enough like just like I thought I
loved her and then this weekend she just
like brought it know effortlessly
brought effortlessly brought it like I
like I follow her self because like I
love her and I've actually learned so
much from her I was telling her at
dinner like I learned a lot about my
skin from her like that I could be over
moisturizing but yes and
I got some tips and tricks to take home
with me but now I'm just even more
invested in her because like she's doing
everything right I couldn't agree more
like I have to start doing hot yoga or
whatever I have to start watching best
sketch oh my god I started watching
Cliff Lee tear okay and I do
laughing literally now I'm recording a
banty neck yeah so she's one of the most
influential in fact this weekend it's on
Teaneck yeah record it because that's
all I know about the timing me too
Plus who watched his life okay speaking
of TV news for some reason Mike Fleiss
and the powers that be here and letting
us know via the mainstream media that I
don't think they had a hand in this no I
do because Dean angler and Kalyn Miller
Keys are dating now paradise is over the
spoilers have been out I heard this
already even though I'm not in spoilers
but obviously there's other things that
have happened too
whenever someone would like all US
magazine and all these magazines and
news like they know who wins
Hanna season right now but they're not
publishing it for some reason Bachelor
people are fine with this going out it's
probably just because it's interesting
press and now I want to see how it
unfolds right but what I found to be
weird was they met in paradise and
nobody knew that Jaden was in paradise
until I was watching Bachelorette last
night and they started doing previews of
paradise and they started and they show
Dean and stuff so like I guess that was
their way of just like saying who came
to artists whatever but in the article
that enews posted they said that they
met like via DM whereas IKEA might have
DM before but like they met in paradise
there's no mention of bachelor in
paradise which I thought to be so weird
oh that is so yeah I think they were
they didn't know that they were spoiling
whoever wrote articles didn't do
research because they said it was an
exclusive and they just like saw
pictures of them and spend together what
it's like yeah they were in paradise and
met and they took a display interesting
or maybe there's enough circumstantial
evidence that they don't have to make it
about paradise and say that it's a
spoiler yeah that's true because I think
that they how the insider said that they
were DMing but like all them do oh yeah
that's in the interesting point you
raise counselors nature I didn't put
that together yeah no I thought it I was
like I was like wow like are they gonna
say like that they're spoiling paradise
right now and they didn't even mention
interesting well they're dating from
paradise
and I'm so here for it I'm a big Caitlyn
fan even in the you know the epic battle
once upon a time between Kalyan and
Hannah that never really shook out or
told us what was going on yeah um I
always like I liked them both but I just
like understood Kailyn I felt for her
during women tell all
no yeah we didn't agree we didn't agree
we did I don't even remember it it
wasn't like because no but we're saying
like that she was saying to kasi like I
hope if I win you're the Bachelorette or
something like that which is just like a
really innocent I don't know this just
goes to show like that's right like you
care about it what you back when it's
happening you care I can't remember what
happened three months ago but i weirdly
shipped this couple they look so much
alike in this picture yeah but I need
you to have my she knows I need you to
see what Dean looks like now what do you
mean he has a huge mustache his hair is
down to here you have to see like that
is not Dean that's Dean no longer okay
so um maybe like you'll see if they look
great together when you see that but I'm
really excited for Paradise I'm so
excited for Paradise if you watch
Bachelorette last night yes I did give
you a chance to recap it at the end okay
so excited for Paradise like the
previews last night like looks so good I
really like feel for Blake because I
just don't think that this is gonna be
his season
I'm just getting like teen vibes yeah so
that should be interesting to watch that
shakeout but I'm super excited I'm
really excited to see the people that we
don't know are there cuz you probably
just showed only the original cast yeah
so um I just feel like this I have a
good feeling about this one
yeah because also I wonder if anyone
from Hannah season who's I currently
still in ended up on paradise but we
just also I think back two seasons ago
when there was the whole scandal with
like Korean and everything yeah I think
it made paradise had kind of take a few
steps backs in terms of like the thirst
and the extra nests and like the you
know it was getting so big and so crazy
and I feel like now we're back to like
it's so like big it was getting like
MTBE yeah Jamie and then they had to
like scale it back okay everyone calm
down but I feel like now everyone
the season came in guns blazing again
yeah and there was no scandal as far as
we know so I just feel like it's gonna
really bring it I'm so excited I like I
ten months for two literally I go
through ten months of the bachelor and
the Bachelorette to watch paradise so
that I have the backstory so that I know
all the facts and I'm so jazzed yeah and
I will be will be watching and I'm gonna
binge watch The Bachelorette
maybe I'll try and do it right before
the finale so that I can care who wins
okay I really don't know the winds right
now I think I do know someone posted in
the toaster it's like in the dumbest
possible way no offense to the person
don't say don't take anything I really
don't know but I'll tell you I have a
feeling I think yes but not by spoiler
they said something about like the
winner and but they didn't say who it
was and then they wrote tags the boat
Charette Hanna and the person's name
like are you [ __ ] kidding me Oh God
oh my god like I can't go on my phone
anymore it's so annoying it was so
annoying I don't even want to look at
the comments no you're good okay um
fifth and final story is a snitch
requested story and I'm here for it
because this is TRL Total Request Live
Baz Luhrmann sets Austin Butler and star
star making Elvis Presley roll opposite
Tom Hanks in a Warner brother film so
there's a new show a movie coming out
about Elvis and Austin Butler have
landed the part and based on the
director the co-stars and the production
house it's gonna be a big [ __ ] movie a
big [ __ ] movie and he it's the world
of a lifetime it's the role of a
lifetime Ashley Tisdale commented on its
Instagram and he's like here he she was
like your entire life is about to change
and like it is and he beat out miles
teller Antal Elgort Harry Harry Styles
which like that's crazy for those of you
who don't know who Austin Butler is he's
dating Vanessa Hudgens he's a former
Disney Channel star he was he is Jake
Ryan he is Jake Ryan he was in the
Carrie Diaries not Jake Ryan did not
know I was said on I said not sure no
he's not maybe but he's from Hannah
Montana Austin Butler
I don't think so Hannah he more
importantly he's Sebastian and Carrie
Diaries oh he's just a random yeah okay
I'm sorry
important I'm sorry guy but um even if
you don't know any of the roles that we
just spoke about if you saw a picture of
him you know exactly who he was
because he like loki was in everything
so [ __ ] hot I think that he I
like I so support this choice like I
appreciate you not going for the obvious
choice like I need to make a new start
like all those other guys like they have
bona fide careers they're going to the
Oscars like they're set for life but
like I'm ready for some new boy Austin
Butler really like he has been working
his ass off to get here taking every
role that he possibly can and just he
finally this is his time to shine
so let's support him people were so mad
about and it's like why he's hot he'll
do a great job he's a great actor give
him a goddamn chance you mean I didn't
chance okay I'm looking at his um his
discography for movies he was in Zoey
101 I'm sure he had like a minor role
but that's exciting he was in Sharpay's
fabulous in that chair exciting and once
upon a time in Hollywood it says so
that's exciting
oh yeah he's in that new movie with Brad
Pitt and Leonardo he's about to be a
real movie star and you know what
Vanessa Hudgens deserves me too I'm
given like the best years of her last
years of her lives and I really hope
that I was thinking about this because
like everything's about to change for
them I hope that this doesn't affect
their relationship you know when people
make it big they lose sight of what's
important I don't think that it will
because like she I think will always be
bigger than him even if she weren't
though like she he will I don't think he
would bite that hand okay like there so
there's nothing he would go do that she
couldn't come along with that's true
yeah cuz every door is open for her yeah
it's just a matter of which one she
wants to walk I agree I agree but I was
just like that I saw that I was like
please make through yeah but it's like
he could be he'll be Zac Efron sized
it's all those well or bigger because
like Zac Efron very much like he doesn't
do like serious roles like this is like
the role of a lifetime
yeah no but Zac Efron is a bona fide
movie star and he'll do like he could
have gotten a role like this if he wants
you
I guess had bundi like oh yeah yeah I
think I take that back I just like every
time thing goes back right now I think
of Baywatch and it's like oh that's
tough yeah but I think Zac Efron will
like go down one day is like our
Brad Pitt you
I think he's making moves I wouldn't I
if I had to choose I'm not getting sand
dances if I had to choose a second out
of those four though as much as I'd love
Harry Styles I would want a miles teller
cook just cuz I love him and I won't say
it whenever hand me Taylor he also can
dance cuz he was in Footloose yeah um
and I love him and I think he would have
done a great job too but I'm very happy
with Austin Butler and I just like love
that they chose the unexpected and he
looks like Elvis my job is there he has
that or maybe that's just natural hair I
don't even know what is Elvis a you know
what he says you know do you know I like
I don't know like what which think
you're talking like when he gets on the
stage or he I forget he says something
like wait let me get up now what does
all this set what does Elvis a Elvis say
when he gets up a lot oh god now there
are all these quotes okay hold on let me
go to like Pinschers quotes okay second
everyone someone will know what I'm
talking about I'm waiting I forget it's
not okay this is painful anyways those
are the five stories and I feel as
though oh my god I accidentally X out a
story that I really wanted to talk about
which is the New York City blackout oh
yes oh my god I'm so glad we were in
here same how [ __ ] scary Everson
saying thank you very much no but that's
it that's the other thing
oh thank you very much yeah but he said
he has as it was like a an adjective or
a noun
no he has the same like he used to say
something as you're saying like awesome
Butler has that no no like when he's
looking at that in that picture he looks
like he could be like same thing remote
okay okay I wasn't even understanding
why you're okay I thought you liked
we're looking for a word thank you very
much for the thing uh very much me okay
the New York City blackout wild wild
wild I'm so glad we were in here even
though it only affected the West
Olivia and Olivia it doesn't look like
we would have been affected but it was
spreading and then it was contained and
it's just really scary and crazy like
that things like this can happen so
easily and as much as we think we are so
advanced like we go back to being like
primal state and people don't know what
to do when people are second elevators
people were starting to side with my
thoughts and prayers are those are with
those who are stuck in the subway um
that I can't I can't even imagine I'm
stuck in elevators there were over 400
elevators that were stuck and the fire
people of New York and police got
everyone out the fire people of New York
and the police are incredible I know and
like it's times like these where you
realize like how wonderful they all are
yeah and I'm just glad that it was
contained and it ended before midnight
because things like this can really
cause anarchy it's like that movie the
purge just all I kept thinking about
could you imagine being in the subway
like the people and I probably took a
long time for people to realize what was
happening and that it was a power outage
and then it's like why is there power
outage is this an attack and then you
just like go through the worst things
that it could possibly be and to be
stuck underground like mentally that
it's just and so I'm like at in
terrifying yeah and then you walk
through the subway like you walk because
the door open um I think you could go
out the back you probably go out the
front Jesus like I can also do you see
the video from jailers concert no but my
wife she literally got up there and they
started singing dancing and all those
people stuck in Madison's where yeah but
everyone like put their flashlights up
and she was like everyone stay calm just
a blackout bla bla bla and then they
evacuated and she's making up last night
like I feel like today's Monday but it's
Tuesday so she made it up last night
just my friend Jordi cuz she shomer
Shabbos and she lives like uptown she
was opposed to go to the concert on
Saturday night so she walked all the way
to Madison Square Garden from her house
because she couldn't take a cab just for
the lights to go out and blackout and
she had to walk back oh my god it's like
the saddest vide ever and then she laid
last night but she like oh my god that's
so sad I know so it was great it was
under control
something interesting now that I got the
paper and I don't know if this is like a
new thing for a newspaper to do but the
front page of the New York Post
yesterday was an op-ed calling for
Governor Cuomo
to fire bill de blasio are you kidding I
just got chills know that I'm not
kidding is like a big thing he was not
in New York when it happened he was in
Iowa campaigning and he is unfit to like
be mayor of the city and let alone
President of the United States to not
even be here when there's a blackout
like the and the city like got back and
got our [ __ ] together like without him
it's like when you get a job that you're
just like not qualified like you know
it's just a family dysfunction they
deserve he does not have the skills and
like I don't know if that's a normal
thing for like newspapers to do but it's
a pretty big deal I saw like been posted
it to and it's just it's time he's gotta
go he's got how many more years left I
put a ridge of his head last term to
know the mayoral term like and never
[ __ ] him and he's get like three or
some [ __ ] yeah like he couldn't go again
nobody can I appreciate as his third and
you should read that I mean this only if
you're a New Yorker like you care if
you're not you don't because it's really
it's not even like a political thing
it's just like a quality-of-life thing
they don't know but it's also just like
it's not even a political thing or an
opinion like it's just a straight-up
fact but yeah he is a terrible mayor the
city has never been in worse shape
nobody never smelled worse you need to
read the article it's just like he's not
even that he's not here he wakes up at
the crack of ten they said when then he
goes to the gym on one side of town then
he goes back to the other side to hang
on them maybe he goes to City Hall and
then he goes back to his house and now
he just like sits and meetings about
being president but like he does not
work for this city he does like so he
shouldn't like sounds were like an
expose yeah it really what it was
enlightening and it was hilarious and so
shady and just really on point like
there was no like more clear no pun
intended
vision of the blackout than him not
being here ya know a hundred percent and
like okay say you weren't here or
whatever like get the [ __ ] back here and
fix it and he was like tweeting like me
and then he get a like I was watching a
press conference when we were in Vegas
because I like wanted to get the updates
and like of course he like takes credit
we got it back up you know like you
didn't do anything you didn't do
anything so it's just a joke and I just
thought that was an interesting factoid
yeah okay
I think it's time to allow you to oh
that's right um
I really don't know anything about how
the season ends for the first time in my
life and I'm just going to continue now
looking at the comments because I don't
want like someone to be an [ __ ] but
um I really don't know where hannah is
going and the thing is like Peter the
pilot is the choice for her but you know
what I don't think she's gonna choose
him but what I will say is that while
Jett annoys the absolute [ __ ] out of me
and I really don't like him when he like
he like gave her like he kind of gave
her a talking-to I was like why like how
is Luke still here when you have like
all three of us and it's like how are
you deciding between me and Luke when
he's literally like a psycho and so
toxic and she was like he was saying all
these things to her like really putting
her in her place and like saying like
that you like to like hold on to like
things you can't let go that are bad for
you like bah blah which is true like the
fact that Luke was still around is
absolutely out of control and she was
like getting mad at him and like he was
like everything he's saying like bro
like this makes sense like it makes no
sense why he's still here but anyways
then she sends him home cuz she finally
like
eyes open to the psycho that is Luke and
she like was she was had a beast she was
so great she knocked him home
everyone's so happy about it then we saw
a preview and he comes back during the
rose ceremony like ready to go and wants
to like be like get back with her and
she literally like she literally was
like screaming at him in the preview
like she was like no like get away like
I hate you but I remember seeing a
preview like four weeks ago of her in
this outfit and Chris Harrison coming up
to her and being like he's here and
wants to propose so I feel like they
didn't show that last night to remind us
but I remember I remember my clients
mature my marriage and I feel like
that's what happens and like all the
guys are like going up to him and
they're like just leave and like he
they're like just leave and he's like
get your hands off me and Tyler's like
or what and it's like a whole like
showdown so that looks good
but the fantasy suites look great Peter
was the one that she [ __ ] in a
windmill twice everyone thought it was
Jenn it was Peter I was very happy to
hear that yes and their date was so cute
their windmill thing was like super nice
she didn't have sex with Tyler they were
open about that do you have you seen
this article
about Peters ex yeah it's not as a
salacious yeah or like evidence-based as
Jen's like jet like she had [ __ ]
picture of a love letter like of him
saying like I just have to go do this
for myself but like I'll be back I love
you like that that was very salacious
like this I think he had a girlfriend
they broke up he went on about to her
like okay so I it didn't concern me like
really at all and I haven't heard any
backlash really about it either
I've real nice I've seen stuff I know
I've seen like people post like on T
news but I haven't seen people being
like oh [ __ ] Peter and the way that they
did with Jed
people hate jet no yeah like everyone
hates jet like if you watched it I mean
like I don't go based on what people say
on Twitter I just hate yet because I
find him unbelievably annoying and not
the person that I want with Hanna the
people hate him because of like the
whole bachelor thing because the
girlfriend yeah and like in the
hometowns like the like the family was
like getting like roll that bad vibes
and everyone was saying it's like
they're like trying to like Warner oh
and there is like whoever the powers
that be like push forward this Peter
thing even if it's like a nothing burger
with his ex so that it's like everyone
hates Luke everyone hates Peter everyone
hates Jen and she can just pick the
Tyler but I don't think she's picking it
oh I didn't realize it was a fourth yeah
I don't think she's picking Tyler
because if so everyone hates them all
equally they won't like [ __ ] on her
right pics but everyone's like favorite
is Tyler but he's almost at a million
followers already like he's the yeah I'm
seeing things about him in the group
like precious gem vacation precious gem
he's so hot like I wouldn't I would love
if he was the bachelor hey more peter i
like i weirdly feel like she's gonna
pick jen and i really hope she doesn't
and that is not a spoiler cuz i actually
have no idea
um but ya know the rest of the season
looks really good I definitely think she
gets engaged that's just like the vibe
that I get but you know she didn't have
sex with Tyler they were soaking about
it she was like cuz all they have is
like chemistry like so she was like I
just want to talk to you to see like if
we have anything else and she was and
she like started crying when he left her
the next morning cuz she like really
liked him I don't know it was like
really cute um but yeah and then I'm
pretty sure her and Jed got it on as
well so she was an exciting night for
Hannah me and you and she was able to
unleash on Luke which was like what
everyone has been waiting for and you
enjoyed the episode I really did enjoy
the episode it's a really good season
and I find her so enjoyable cuz she's
like so quirky and like not so like
toys and like trying to be perfect which
like I appreciate okay I I mean I trust
the the snitch Lorette yeah recaps no
she's she's really good I just like I
really have no for the first time in
maybe years I have no idea what's gonna
happen it's just so you think she's
gonna have a happily ever after where
she like goes home with her man and
they're making hellofresh meals
oh for sure and also the only reason why
I think Jed wins is because do you
remember when like that whole Gower
thing happened with the likes and like
he won and happens so early on he that
couldn't really say anything
so Jed posted an Instagram like four
days ago being like what I can't say
something like I will like blah blah
blah if you do and when you I feel like
you could just put out a statement um
well you're still on the show you can't
you can't do any press you can't address
any of it no so any like even if like so
Peter can't address his ex if he's on
the show I got yeah they can't do
podcast nothing that's true
I just really I'm saying it so that it
doesn't happen okay do you not I mean I
understand well I hope they live happily
ever after with their hellofresh just
like us because I am loving hello fresh
it is helping me like get my cooking
groove on without having to like be you
know so prepared because it does
everything for you hello fresh makes
meals simple they make cooking delicious
meals at home a reality regardless of
your comfort in your kitchen from
step-by-step recipes to pre-measured
ingredients you'll have everything you
need to get a WoW worthy dinner on the
table in just about 30 minutes say
goodbye to and list grocery store trips
and takeout food hello fresh has you
covered that is my [ __ ] cross to bear
and list grocery store trips I don't
talk about food you can break out of
your dinner route with seventeen
seasonal chef curate recipes chef
curated recipes each week there's
something for everyone and family
recipes to calorie smart and vegetarian
and fun menu series like Hall of Fame
and craft burgers I love the vegetarian
plan because I mean I'm for the most
part of vegetarians yeah and they just
get so inventive and all of a sudden
like I'm having and chihuahuas and
that's exciting that is so exciting you
can add extra meals to your weekly order
as well as yummy sides like garlic bread
and cookie dough easily change your
delivery days food preferences and skip
a week whenever you need so it's super
flexible fits your lifestyle at your
schedule no sweat anyways I love how
well fresh it's really helping
like more comfortable in the kitchen I'm
taking some cooking classes which I
canal up it makes me it helps with
hellofresh but like it also helps you
like to understand what they're asking
me to do right but I don't I'm not
cooking from scratch yet because I'm not
there yet and I don't have to be with
hellofresh so if you want to try
hellofresh
get eighty dollars off your first month
first month of hellofresh
go to hello fresh comm slash toast
eighty and enter code toast eighty
that's hello fresh comm slash toast
eighty and enter code toast eighty
that's like receiving eight meals
straight with the $80 off you get your
$20 you get $20 off your first four
boxes technically if you go to hello
fresh comm slash toast eighty and use
code toasty and we need to do that
because I've actually really been
wanting to start cooking but I just
cannot get myself to go to the
supermarket I think you could be a hell
of fresh sort of snitch maybe I finally
got pots and pans that's I think that's
really all you need and a knife I know I
don't know if I've actually they cut
stuff for you - okay so movie I don't
even think I have knives yet so
hilarious well wow that is our show
really I feel like there's so much more
I know to discuss I'm like starting to
sweat like I feel like I'm on the plane
again
oh god keep it together I don't know
what just happened I'm like having a lot
hopefully quite we'll be back tomorrow
and feeling better
I'm not sure though that's she will I'm
not sure though that I haven't heard any
anything about it getting better like I
think she's still in the weeds yeah like
she still couldn't sleep last night and
that's when you know but tomorrow we
have Nikki bio joining us yes
so that'll be super fun I'm excited to
pick his brain about Dean and Kailyn cuz
Dean and Nick are very good friends
totally we'll talk some snatch Lirette
some yes special all right
I'm working on it I don't even know what
like what you're talking about
I like the snatch lorette for snitches
Bachelorette recaps okay okay this NASA
right yeah that's a good one cuz
snitches a little too um polarizing a
term oh no I was going to say it's just
too nice
me sure um so that'll be fun when we
come back to see what's going on in his
love laugh um hopefully Corleone will be
here with me if not you know the snitch
is a reliable source or you could host
with Nick but um I enjoyed the snitch I
could I could do both get you a girl who
could do both ya know whatever you want
and that's all she wrote all she wrote
she do this week I
and even next week is a dark week for us
we are on vacation and that I am looking
forward to because it's like all the
vacations that I've taken in the last
six months are actually more torture
than my actual life yeah I feel that you
know this is not I don't think anyone
will call this a vacation no I don't it
was a um just a trip when I'm sure we
went on a trip it was definitely like a
business trip did you gamble at all yeah
how'd you do I lost and then I am tapped
out Chatterley with gambling cuz I was
like you don't need no it's just like
your luck isn't changing its not going
your way
that's what happened so I just like I
was like I rather save my money so I
lost like hundred bucks at all I didn't
sit down as a table once like I didn't
gamble once in honestly good for you but
they got a cool new film I was gonna say
um indulge your other addiction that's
true I indulge my other addiction which
is shopping cuz Vegas has some great
shops I got this sweet phone case which
is like as far as big purchases that's
not so bad
no it's so cute so as like addiction
wise hey look I didn't go crazy either
that's good
I didn't shop thank God Mike that's the
last thing on it I bet I need to be
doing well anyways we love you thank you
all for tuning in we missed you so much
we will be back tomorrow with another
great show no matter who's in narratives
host it's chair will be filled oh yes
definitely the end another chair and and
then maybe that chair of Claudia is here
right so we will see you tomorrow have a
great day everyone make sure you were
subscribe to us on YouTube subscribe to
us in the podcast app even if you like
you too don't listen you can just
subscribe just in case it's good to have
him downloaded on your phone in case you
wind up on a plane that doesn't have a
television we had one we had one but
some people didn't in our in oceans 25
ocean 25 also follow me on Instagram I'm
really trying to get to 100k
at my roster and she's so premium she's
so influential she does like the best
brand yells partnerships advertisements
I just want to buy everything with my
allowance I have one going up later
today so exciting for everyone and
follow me on instagram at Jackie O
problems I've been like blowing it up
left and right I have new presets coming
out this week that are so fun so summery
then I use them about every single one
of my posts from Vegas oh yeah they're
just like super brightening and fun and
colorful and it's just a great addition
if you're addicted to presets like I am
so I will keep you posted on all of that
and we will see you tomorrow
they lie
you